let's talk about where this leads to as
not only the result of this ideology but
one of the tactics in the ideology and
we got the story from newsweek which i
find absolutely
sad it's sad and funny police prepare
for another hot summer of violent street
clashes as u.s
reopens really nothing's even happened
yet
what what what kovid is gonna cause this
what the getting people getting back
from covet is gonna cause riots i don't
think that's what no i think what
they're saying
is that regardless the the police are
getting prepared
because even though there's been no
police brutality even though there's
been no major breaking story the cops
know
that doesn't matter right you'll get a
video of a you know i'll tell i'll give
you an example there's a cop playing
basketball with the local kids and
they're all laughing one of the kids
happens to be black and the cop
he he he's you know he's going up to to
you know do a jump shot he jump shots
and then he bumps into one of the kid
the kid falls over and then everyone has
a clip of a cop bumping into a kid and
knocking him over and they're like
please brutality
i'm exaggerating obviously but the point
i'm making is you'll get something out
of context
you'll get some hip hop some some
hearsay some
random rumor and then all of a sudden
here we go again you know what else that
article is saying is our company
newsweek
is flailing and losing money and we're
desperate for
clicks so here's some rage bait crap
well and here's the funny thing though
the cops are getting ready i'll tell you
what the cops are getting ready to do
they're loading their stuff to get out
of the way for the riots because their
civilian leaders are not going to let
them stop
those riots and like you said they got a
the most recent incident cop shoots a
kid
who had a gun doesn't matter that the
kid had a gun you know he was 15.
he had a gun he got shot the cops are
supposed to shoot that kid
when he points a gun at him let's talk
they're not supposed to take a bullet
let's talk about those two girls in dc
who carjacked that guy right yeah
carjacked him
committing a felony killed him they're
not going to get jail time
no kyle rittenhouse defending a local
business
chased and attacked by a violent rioter
of violent rioters
fires in self-defense and immediately
runs to get police assistance he's
injured
those girls carjacked that guy and then
hit the gas and
murdered him threw him out of his car
and murdered him no jail time
at one level 13 and 15 i'm like
they're not adults you know i i'm i'm
having 17 to
elevate that but it also sends a message
that oh keep carjacking
now rittenhouse will get off i i i have
looked at that i'm
actually writing a piece that i'm going
to give to the defense
justifying why that is self-defense by
every
legitimate legal standard but why did he
get charged
with first-degree murder i'll tell you
why because black lives matter
intimidated
the civilian leaders through violence
into changing their policy and charging
with that now what's that that's
domestic terrorism it is we haven't
we have no real leaders we have no
reason no one is immune to
uh belligerence like i mean i just keep
thinking of nazi germany man they
thought they were
dem they were democracy up until that
point the german people and
if violent coercion can happen at any
time to any group of people so we have
to be
we have to be aware of that we have to
be cognizant that that can take hold man
and that's there's no leaders bro
they're they're defining leader i know
where where was the prosecutor from
wisconsin to walk out and say
i'm not charging him with a crime have a
nice day
in the same place in in minneapolis were
or anyplace else
because and but here's the dangerous
thing black lives matter has now been
told
that violence to intimidate public
policy works
so they committed terrorist acts those
were used to change policy
and now they were rewarded with hundreds
of millions of dollars in revenue
and the policies they want so we're in a
situation where there are now two rules
all right we had an afternoon of
violence at the capitol and that was the
greatest insurrection and biggest threat
to the republic in the history of earth
and we had an entire year plus of
insurrection by the left
and it's like meh you know because
excuse me excuse me
excuse me no no no no those were
peaceful protests mostly
mostly fiery but peaceful 93 one of the
best
ever and no fiery but mostly peaceful
protest
but the threat of violence doesn't even
have to be violence now now here's where
they won
they committed the violence and they
will again because hey i mean somebody
needs flat screen
you know flat screens are in high demand
but whatever justification they use to
start the riots
those will happen the police will not
stop them again
and again people now kyle rittenhouse
was literally
acting as a member of the militia not
the militia by name that kenosha guard
or whatever it was
but the in the second amendment it is
expected that in the absence of
government authority to keep people safe
they have the right and the ability to
protect themselves
themselves and their property so he went
and protected property at the invitation
of the owners
and with with a with and he did not
bring a gun across state lines no
his friend gave him a gun okay and the
issues about should he have had the gun
he's 17 okay those are legitimate
deal with those but that's
administrative right the right
of people in the absence of the police
the police were stood down
and pulled back and people's businesses
and livelihoods and lives were
threatened
they have a right to have weapons and to
protect themselves
that's what the militia is here's
another question does the second
amendment say
the uh a well-regulated militia be
necessary for you know
free free estate the right to keep and
bear arms shall not be infringed comma
unless of course you are under the age
of 18
you have a mental illness you are a
felon it doesn't actually say any of
those things no
now i understand there's interpretations
in you know from the supreme court
but i wonder which of those would
actually stand in the long run because
you know back then what a 15 year old
was an adult
they could have guns and i think biden
as much as he
is a doddering fool and an idiot and
said some dumb things today
of course no amendment is absolute all
right there there are no
actual absolutes in politics it's not
possible to have an absolute in politics
but what you can say is under the
interpretations and the standing law and
precedent
right now the things he's doing are
unconstitutional
as per heller versus dc or dc versus
heller you know that i would do if i was
in congress
i would create the two plus two equals
four bill and it would simply say
congress asserts that two plus two
equals four that's it
you gonna vote on it or not because they
tried saying the woke people two plus
two could equal five
i would i would probably filibuster that
because in base three math there is no
numeral four you only have zero one two
matter it's always the geek
it's always they got you i'm the number
but this is this is exactly the the
constructivist ideology that i can
change the definition in order to make
you wrong
as opposed to admitting what we know is
two plus two equals four
you can change the context but now
you're arguing something totally
different
it would be like if we were playing
baseball and i said if i hit this ball
a hundred feet and it goes over that
fence it's a home run you go
well some fences are at 75 feet some are
at 150 feet i'm like i didn't ask that
i'm talking about this fence right here
so what they're doing is they're going
well two plus two could equal five
because what if we're saying two point
four
plus two point four which is four point
eight which rounded up is five well you
didn't say two
two point four did you based so so the
point is you said in base ten
wow or above 2 plus 2 equals 4 i cannot
deny that what
average person is thinking in anything
other than base 10 right now probably
none of them
none of them so this is the
constructivist ideology
to change the definition to manipulate
the results
look at the best one they did all right
they changed the definition of racism
right so that you have to be in a
position of power
in order to be a racist so that black
people and other people of color and
and other identity groups that are our
preferred victim
groups cannot be racist that's garbage
you know once you do that it's the same
as as saying okay now men
women male female okay those words male
female still i think are xxxy
right anymore but i changed it did they
so
man woman means nothing regular people
in this country
will say male and female are specific
they
they relate specifically to the gametes
you know sperm or egg
in woke nomenclature male and female are
arbitrary concepts that don't mean
anything right and they say
they've said this for years now in a
debate with jordan peterson there was
one
uh university employee historian of
medicine who said
that biological sex is not a real thing
which is just absolutely untrue
they're doing these things that's why i
was like right now you have an
opportunity to pass a bill says two plus
two equals four
you'll probably get some opposition no
joke okay you will
but that's good so excuse me we can
stand up and say
okay that's bs you know and that's the
problem
is for too long they've been unopposed
and they've been doing that they've been
changing definitions and people were
like i'm busy i got to get my kids to
soccer practice right
well you can no longer get your kids to
soccer practice in this country
if they're going to do what they're
doing you have to spend some of your
time
fighting back against wokeness or we
will no longer have a republic
where your kids are allowed to play
soccer the racist thing i can't i can't
wrap my head around it's like some
debates i can have two plus two equals
four okay
there's multiple bases of mathematics
four doesn't exist in all of them
the racist thing to say that just
because a class or or a group of people
are
are prejudiced against that it's
impossible for them to be racist
against other other types is in that i
can't
i can't come to terms with but that's
what they want and that's i mean it's
all 1984. all right orwell did this
you know back long ago the idea is to
tell you
what truth is and confuse you so you
can't oppose it
because they want power and you get
power by forcing people to accept
your version of the truth that's why
they say let me give you my truth
right no and rest in power yeah no there
is no
your truth you have your opinion right
it's not your truth
there is truth there is falsehood there
is good there is evil
there are absolutes in philosophical
ideas like that
there are not absolutes in politics and
what they want to do is flip that on its
head
and give you their absolutes in politics
which is that
black people can't be racist and expect
you not to
go no flag on the play you're sorry
have you seen the winnie the pooh meme
where it's like a regular winnie the
pooh then it says a word then it's
him wearing a monocle then him wearing a
suit there's one where it's regular
winnie the pooh and it says my opinion
then it's him with a monocle and like a
mustache and it says anecdotal evidence
and then the bottom one is him in a
tuxedo and it says my lived experience
[Laughter]
but okay there you are you know as long
as you can say it is
how i feel because it's all about the
feels you know the left lives on emotion
all right and and wokeness is all about
trying to create a society where people
can't be
judged as good bad or indifferent and
they can't be
offended they have a right to be free
from offense
which conflicts with the first amendment
which was designed
so i can offend you i'm sorry it
conflicts with reality
like i i get offended by the woodpecker
who keeps banging on the tree outside
what am i going to do about it sometimes
things exist
i get offended by the rain how dare you
rain i'm trying to skateboard right here
some things you can't do anything about
well you can get a bb gun and take care
of that woodpecker well yeah
unless it's a red-cockaded woodpecker in
which case you can't because
it's protected well the idea is you
could be sitting in your own home
sitting there with your gut hanging out
drinking a beer and eating your
fifth slice of pizza and amy schumer
comes on and you go
she's nasty and then they they they find
out
and they freak out and they get mad how
dare you say that
you're fat phobic also like if two
people are hanging out and one person
feels offense who who did the offending
was it was this person offended or did
this person
offend or or did did this person receive
it
or or crea you can't
i feel this so you made me feel it it's
no no no i made myself feel this way
based on my surroundings that i the way
i perceive it teaches that you should
look for a fence i mean they literally
teach that's why the grievance is so
important the grievance is the basest
for wokeness because you need the
grievance to create a need for spoils
and reparations so are they is this this
like
proactive defense thing like i think
they're gonna harm me in the future so
i'm going to i'm going to come out hard
and strong and
no no no no bomb the country i want
power
so i'm going to manipulate people to get
power it's that simple yeah right now
a lot a lot of people you ever see fight
club yeah these are
just remember that line from edward
norton where he's like a lot most people
will do everything
in their power to avoid getting into a
fight yeah the woke people figured that
out
so they go into your workplace and
you're sitting there typing away on your
computer like i want to get my job done
and they go
excuse me dude that's terror did you
have a turkey sandwich
turkey is racist because the pilgrims
used turkey as a symbol of their
colonial colonization when they killed
the native americans
you can't be eating turkey today because
it's indigenous day
and then you know people do i'm i'm so
sorry i had no idea i'm so sorry
i don't want to get into a fight i don't
want to i don't want to deal with this
can i just go home now
it's like low-key terrorism it's
literally without a doubt it's
information warfare against you
and the only answer to it is to not care
right i mean that's that's my favorite
thing when i wrote myth of white
fragility i'm like
i wonder if i'm going to get called a
racist
and after the 65 thousandth time
it didn't bother me to start with right
because i know i'm not
but the idea now that everyone needs to
be able to stand up and say no you can
call me that
but it doesn't change my lived reality
right which is that i'm not and so i'm
going to stand up and say shut up
it could be in a jerk you know i got
work to do first of all get out of here
and second of all i'm having another
turkey it's amazing to me how many
people try to convince these woke people
that they're not actually racist i'm
like bro they know you're not racist
they don't care
like i tweeted something on this phone
on twitter right so i had this big rant
on a couple different nights about
campaign finance and how i really really
think it's wrong that billionaires can
dump hundreds of millions of dollars
to for instance ban gun rights i i say
that one because it should resonate with
people who want second amendment
when you get tom steyer and bloomberg
spending you know 500 million bucks
to convince people guns to be banned by
lying about what an assault weapon is
even though it's that doesn't really
define anything that makes me angry
the same is true for any billion i don't
care what they're pushing i don't like
the idea that someone's going to spend
money
go into your district and then tell all
your neighbors to vote against their own
rights i got a problem with that
so we get this thing where uh marjorie
taylor green she raises 3.2 million
dollars in her first quarter
aoc only raised 768k so marjorie taylor
green has raised nearly five times as
much
as aoc did in her first quarter and so i
quote tweeted and i just put
hahahahahahahahahaha
i'm laughing you know i'm laughing
because they like to talk about the
millionaires and the billionaires and
i've been complaining about external
donations into districts to manipulate
politics
i was laughing about marjory taylor
green because it shows the media's
smears backfired
and campaign finance which they don't
care about aoc
is now propping up something they don't
like but these people don't
so what happens is they tweeted me like
see you clearly support marjory taylor
green i'm like
i'm not gonna argue with you because
you're an idiot i know you're you have
no idea what you're talking about
it's just tribalism where they pretend
they pretend where they're like
are you actually gonna defend marjorie
taylor green and i was like what about
hahahahaha is defending anybody
like please explain that to me the best
part about that was where you showed the
part where google translated it
together yeah yeah yeah the translation
was i think your ai needs some work yeah
yeah
there wasn't even a translation that was
the best yeah so google offered to
translate it for me and i
you're saying don't bother defending
yourself against it i think that's a
great
statement because i mean if an alligator
wants to fight you underwater it's going
to drag you into water
you're going to lose that fight exactly
you got to make them go on land
so one thing i always look out for when
people actually try and debate you
a common tactic of dim-witted or
mid-wooded individuals
is to force you to fight underwater it's
a good good analogy in
and so what will happen is they'll it's
martin bailey they'll say i think x and
you'll go
while x is this and they'll go well
actually but why no we're not talking
about why i don't care
never let them redirect someone will
like uh so there's a guy i know who like
tweets at me
and he quote tweets me and he'll say
something like tim poole did x i'll
respond with actually i did y
and then he'll change the subject change
the subject and be like yeah well don't
you remember when you did z
and i'll be like when it comes to y i
just totally disregard any attempt at
derailing and dragging me underwater i
won't even mention it
they want to derail you and there's
literally no reason to talk about
something you want to talk about
so don't fight don't fight an alligator
underwater if someone says it's a quote
from me
do you think a or b you don't have to
say
a or b you can say whatever you your
answer can be anything you
do not have to answer questions the way
people want you like ian what color is
this guy doesn't matter
so we do we've got free will we can
literally do
what we want we don't have to do what
they say that's true that's a great way
to fight what
people are scared i know and that's the
problem all right and they should be
scared
because they're very good at hurting you
all right they're attacking your
livelihood
you know they'll attack you at your
family they'll attack you at your work
they can get you fired all right that
hurts regular people
in a real way that's why we have to band
together now we don't have to form you
know support groups
and have safe spaces for people on the
right to say oh the wokeness is is
making me feel bad
we just have to do what you did it's
telling i'm not going to play your game
i don't even say it you didn't care
don't even acknowledge the game
i think at some level you have to with
this but
you can do you can stop them from the
redirect you can say no no i'm just
talking about what you just did
you said i'm a racist for eating turkey
that's garbage
and if you want to go anywhere from
there i'm not gonna i'm not gonna
indulge you
but i don't believe eating turkey is
racist neither do you
you're a jerk for bringing it up you
want you wanna know what i would do i'd
show up the next day with
turkey sandwiches for the entire office
yes we we had we had vosh
on the show do you know washes and i had
some
you know right personalities say like i
can't believe you would invite this
person on your show
and so my response is i'm gonna book
them again it's like dude i don't play
that game
you're not scared of a different opinion
you're not scared of people who disagree
with you you don't feel they have to be
isolated and pushed out and and
quarantined
i i think if we we we need to talk to
people
did you get a backstage how'd that work
man how'd you get that i'm stuck
how could you have people with different
opinions on your show i lived in madison
wisconsin all right which is
one of the reddest cities on earth i was
introduced by everyone who knew me there
as this is jim my conservative friend
because i was the only one they knew
right yet we managed to co-exist
all right we managed to disagree we
managed to say that hey okay you have
because what i do with them is i say
look i think we have the same goal
i think we both want people to be safe
and prosperous and live their lives and
and not
be killed by things all right but i
think we have different
methods that we think will achieve that
and i think mine
are more effective and here's why i
think yours are less effective
and if in the end we don't agree we go
our separate ways we vote
and we continue to live as americans the
problem with woke-ism is you can't
do that because they think if you don't
follow their way
you are actually literally causing harm
and they
they have actually a religious duty to
them
to stop you thanks for checking out this
clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you